I don't want people to look down upon me for having a gay son.
Our kids don't exist to bolster our reputation.
A child is amazing,
but I can't rely on her to do that.
That's not her role.
The Voice of God is the still small voice inside your own heart and that voice
is saying let love do what love does.
I'm Adam Greenwald.
I'm a husband.
I'm a rabbi and I'm the director of the Miller introduction to Judaism program
at American Jewish University.
Hi,
I'm Adam Edgerly.
I am a husband,
father of a daughter and pastor of new Song La Church.
My name is Amy Boyle.
I am an atheist,
a humanist and the director of a local secular community Sunday assembly Los
Angeles.
Okay.
My mother smokes weed and I hate it.
I know it's her house,
but she is always smoking like what?
16 year olds,
parent hot boxes,
the living room.
How do I confront her?
Maybe you could talk to your mother,
but also in the context of lifting to any concerns or annoyances she might have
so you can give a little and take a little
showing your kid.
The image of somebody who sits around and smokes weed all day.
It's not only the vice of smoking marijuana,
whether that's such a serious vice or not,
it's how you're using that opportunity of parenthood.
I want to respect the fact that we're only hearing half,
half the story.
Like you said,
we don't know if there's like a chronic pain issue or what the rest of that
story looks like.
It seems like the conversation,
you'd almost want to direct it away from the substance and talk about let's go
deeper.
Plf feel it.
You know what's really going on there.
When I ended my pot-smoking days,
it was my mother that got me to stop and she didn't get me to stop by ordering
me to stop.
It was because I saw how it affected her.
When you're living in your parent's home,
you have to respect your parents rules.
I would suggest pleading with mom saying,
this is how it's impacting me because when I saw my mother grieving over what
was happening to me and it was basically she saw me wasting my potential.
I saw the pain and that's what convinced me to stop.
Okay.
I posted a Ryan Reynolds Deadpool meme about how Santa isn't real on Facebook
and my 13 year old niece side and told my 11 year old niece,
they are devastated.
My sister and parents are angry at me and want to lie about Santa being real.
I don't think it's healthy to do so at their ages.
What can I do to smooth things over?
Well,
so I'm the Jew with the table.
[inaudible] right.
Um,
so that was me.
I did also,
I played Santa Claus for a couple of years at a children's hospital on Christmas
Eve.
So I think that I may be the only rabbi in America who also has my resume,
a time in which I was playing Santa.
But through college I would put on the red suit and Schlep around a Gurney of
presence from room to room.
And I got to the room of this 1516 year old gang member who had been shot.
And I opened the door and he took one look at me and he leapt out of bed.
He was so excited to see Santa Claus and I'm thinking like,
here's this kid.
Hold on.
One hand is out getting shot in the street involved in gang activity.
On the other hand,
when Santa comes to his door in his hospital room,
he just wants to give Santa a hug and I think in that moment I got a little bit
of why that magic is important in a way that I'd never understood as a Jew
before.
Oh,
interesting perspective because of my Christian faith,
I told my daughter from the very beginning,
there is no Santa Claus.
I think it can be damaging if,
especially as people of faith,
there are a lot of things that we're going to be teaching our children that may
be difficult to believe,
right?
So it's challenging to believe in the creator that you can't see and so forth.
I don't think we need to be lying to our kids and then later on tell him what we
lied about that,
but we were telling the truth about this.
I think that's a credibility problem.
In this particular case though,
I want to speak specifically to this case.
If the kid has already heard that there's no Santa Grieve with the child,
don't reinforce the lie because it's going to come out later and it'll be worse
later.
I'm an atheist and I have four year old,
uh,
and we,
we decided to to have Santa's be real for them.
My husband and I both really loved that magic and that sense of wonder and also
because we thought that that makes a good teachable moment,
that process of kids figuring that out.
I also really respect the choice that you made advice for this person.
I think just being honest about where your intention came from,
right?
That you weren't trying to spoil anything or make them grow up before they were
ready.
And I think if,
if a child stops believing in Santa,
that's it's because they're ready.
Hi,
grandfather molested me when I was a child.
I told my father and he didn't do anything about it.
17 years later,
my grandfather is now dying and my family wants me to visit him.
I think confronting my dad and telling the rest of my family would not be well
timed.
Do I tell my mom and confront my dad?
Now do I tell them that I can't say why I won't be visiting,
but that'll tell them in a few months after my grandfather's death.
I don't believe that you have a responsibility to go visit your grandfather.
I appreciate your love for your parents and your willingness to not spoil their
time of grief for him,
but the fact is they should have protected you.
Forgiveness comes after a taking of responsibility by the person who committed
the act as there's been no taking of responsibility.
You don't owe him
anything.
Actually,
I think it's possible to forgive when,
when there is an acknowledgement of wrongdoing.
Uh,
but I think it's hard and I don't think it's owed.
I would agree with that.
I would make a distinction between forgiveness and reconciliation.
Reconciliation is
flooring of the relationship.
I think forgiveness can be unilateral.
Sometimes people feel like in order to forgive,
they need to be able to empathize with the person who victimized them.
Um,
and so I much prefer there's a,
there's a concept that comes out of the Jewish tradition called,
Yay.
Gosh.
When you've lost something and you know you're never going to get it back.
Hmm.
What may be we're counseling together is,
is there a way to take this burden off of your heart so you can walk away a
little bit freer?
Right.
Yeah.
It sounds like we all agree that there's nothing owed to the grandfather or
maybe even the parents and then the situation.
There's just coping with this however they can.
Yeah.
My son recently came out to my wife and I as gay,
but I'm having a hard time accepting it.
My parents always told me growing up that homosexuality is wrong.
I don't want people to look down upon me for having a gay son.
I still love my son.
I'm just having a hard time coming to grips with his sexuality.
Hmm.
Wow.
That's a very honest post.
Showing love and acceptance for your son has to be more important than your own
personal reputation.
Our kids don't exist to bolster our reputation.
My child is amazing,
but I can't rely on her to do that.
That's not her role.
Coming out of the Christian tradition,
how sex is expressed is pretty narrow and pretty clear in scripture.
Um,
I think that doesn't supersede the command to love and respect everyone and
especially a member of your own family.
Amen,
pastor.
Part of our obligation as leaders in spiritual traditions or in wisdom
traditions is to give people the permission to trust the voice inside of them,
right?
A lot of people put a lot more weight on the voice that comes through the book
or the voice that came through the preacher,
the voice of God.
However you understand that is the still small voice inside your own heart.
That voice is saying you need to grow and you need to let love do what love
does,
which is to win out in the end.
That voice,
as a secular person,
I have that as well.
We just don't call it God.
It's sort of liberating not to be bound to dogma or scripture or something that
might come into conflict with what it actually feels.
Right.
Your son came out to you and gave you that gift of trusting you.
It sounds like he believes that your relationship is strong enough and it sounds
like you were ready.
Uh,
so I,
I do think you're most of the way there,
one thing I is that we all recognized the fathers urge to love and accept his
son and he's asking how do I get there and that we all affirm get there.
Right?
Would you say that's true?
Yeah.
He's counting on you.
We're all dealing with the same stuff even more than the answers around the
table.
The questions were for me,
a reminder of our common humanity.
So many places,
15 lake,
we were coming from the same place.
Um,
and that our,
our moral instincts are the same.
Uh,
we find inspiration and attribute the origin of those instincts from Dan,
sometimes different places.
Talking to people from different backgrounds is very helpful.
I think that when we isolate,
we are the poorer for it.
Hey guys,
chased him from jubilee here.
We hope you enjoyed that video.
We know that this is kind of a tougher topic,
but we hope that at the end of the day,
we've offered you some value and some empathy.
As always,
make sure you let us know in the comments below what you thought.
Click here to subscribe.
Click here to watch more videos and we'll see you guys next time.
Okay.